-Our next guest is a
Grammy-winning musician
and front man of the band Wilco.
His book,
"How to Write One Song,"
and his latest solo album,
"Love Is the King,"
are both available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Jeff Tweedy.
How are you, Jeff?
-I'm good. How are you?
Good to see you.
-I'm doing very well.
We've talked in the past.
As you know, I'm a longtime fa
of yours and of Wilco,
and I had this great honor
You asked a bunch of friends
of yours to be
in the video for your new song
"Gwendolyn,"
and I was lucky enough to be
one of those people.
How did you come up
with this idea?
Here I am.
It's basically the bottom half
of my face,
the top half of yours.
And how did you come up
with the idea?
-I saw a post on social medi
from Steve Martin,
where he was joking
that nobody recog--
Something was weird
about going out in public,
so he had made a sign to wea
over his head that said,
"This is Steve Martin."
And it made me think that I have
a lot of friends that
are sort of celebrities,
and they don't get to use
that part of their face
very much anymore.
So I thought maybe I could tak
advantage of that
and get everybody to donat
their face to my video.
Plus, just masks just work
really well as a green screen,
so I just thought I'd take
advantage of our moment
in that way.
-Well, I really appreciate being
part of that moment.
You recorded this album
with your family,
and I imagine, at this point
Wilco must feel like famil
when you record songs,
but it must also still be
so different to do
with your actual family.
What's that like?
-It's -- Playing music
with your family
is just the most amazing gif
I can ever imagine being given
It's -- You know, music relies
upon trust and, you know,
just faith that you're going t
be there in a supportive rol
for each other, and musician
work long -- I don't know.
They work for
a long time, usually.
A band has to be together
for years
to develop all of those
types of trusts.
And a family just kind of
has it as a --
starting point, a base, yo
know, level of trust that is -
I don't know.
It just feels like you just have
so much more room
to get intimate from there
So it's the best
thing I can think of to do
-Hey, congrats on the book
This is basically -- You'r
trying to give people advice o
how to write one song.
And one of the things that
you sort of stress is
how important it is to
let inspiration in,
to invite it in.
Can you explain
that a little bit?
-Well, everybody, I think,
imagines that artistic processes
require, like, a bolt of
lightning, like, an inspiration.
And my argument is that
nobody that --
Nobody's just walking down
the street and has no intentio
to write a song is going to ge
hit by a bolt of lightning
and decide to write a song
You basically have to put
yourself in the path
of that kind of inspiration,
and I think you do that
by just working at
it when you're not inspired,
working at it as a daily -
you know,
just a practice that you have,
a habit that you have
to remind yourself
to just kind of be open
to things.
And then it happens
all the time.
It tends to happen almost
every day for me
that I get
a little bit inspired,
and, sometimes,
I get a lot inspired,
but it wouldn't happen at all if
I didn't pick up the penci
or pick up a guitar.
And that's what I just think
everybody should do.
-You mentioned that, you know,
it's important to, you know,
build it as a skill and make i
work and sit down and do it.
With that said,
are there still times
when you think of a lyric
and you just know right away
"Oh, that's really good"?
-Sometimes, yeah.
I was driving out on
the tollway the other day,
and there was a hearse
stuck at a toll plaza.
Like, the guy driving the hearse
didn't have any change
and they didn't have an E-ZPas
or anything like that.
And I just felt like
I was hit over the head
with the world's
greatest metaphor.
And I sang it into my phon
before I even pulled over,
you know?
-Well, the classic case of
someone else's loss
is your gain.
-Like, what a way to go, man
-Hey, one of the things that's
always fascinating to me
about the Grammys
more than any other awards sho
is just the breadth of the kin
of artists you have
at a Grammys versus, you know,
just different
kind of actors or, you know,
a comic and a dramatic actor
Your first Grammys
is a perfect example of this
some of the people
you bumped into.
-Yeah. I think my most
notable encounter was --
I was with
a big group of people,
all the Wilco guys
and wives and girlfriends.
And, somehow, I ended up outside
one of the bathrooms
at the Staples Center holdin
everyone's program
for the Grammys.
I just had a stack
of Grammy programs,
and P. Diddy walked up to me
and he thought I was an ushe
handing out programs.
And he tapped the programs tha
I was holding with a cane.
He's like,
"Give me one of those."
And I'm like, "No.
They're mine."
And it didn't become -- It
didn't escalate, thank goodness.
But I was also mista--
Every time I've ever
gone to the Grammys, I've been
mistaken for a seat filler
And they're like, "Go! Get out!"
-What I'd like to think is tha
P. Diddy both thought you were
handing out programs
and also recognized you
and then said, "Do you know that
lead singer of Wilco
is also an usher?"
-Yeah, that would have bee
just as plausible.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Thanks for sticking around
to do some music for us.
And congratulations on the book.
-My pleasure.
Great to see you again.
-Great to see you, too.
"How to Write One Song"
and "Love Is the King"
are both out now.